[Music]
so
the first set of teasers for godzilla vs
score movie has been released
last month and again now sometime back
yesterday
in the one that we saw last month it was
a short three second clip of godzilla
swimming and kong roaring out loud
at this rate we are going to have
everything in the movie spoiled for us
just kidding i'm bad at humor in this
more recent clip which is even shorter
like three seconds wasn't enough or too
long for legendary oh my god okay we get
to see godzilla rising up from the ocean
into the aircraft carrier and then the
second part was kong
swinging his arm for a punch and finally
the third part which is godzilla getting
punched in the face
so our big party pooper question is how
can the aircraft carry stay afloat
when both kong and godzilla are on top
of it is it even possible
or is it a plot hole that is just
ignored because the scene was super
awesome
i'm guessing the latter but before you
raise your eyebrows and clench your fist
to give me that kong punch
i beg you to hear me out in this video
we are going to showcase and discuss the
buoyancy of the ship
its displacement and if the scene is a
possibility so here it goes
how do ships float have you ever
wondered how a ship made of steel can
float
if you drop a steel bolt into a bucket
of water the ball quickly sinks to the
bottom
then how can a steel ship float and
better yet how can a steel ship carry a
heavy load without sinking
it has to do with the density of the
ship including its cargo relative to the
density of water
but because of its body design which
contains a lot of air it
pushes aside enough water to so that the
buoyancy force is equal to the gravity
force
that is why a ship floats in fact a ship
does not float on the surface of the
water
it sinks in the water a bit with a part
of its hull below the surface
displacement for example if you build a
box with
no lid one meter into 0.5 meters into
0.5 meters on the outside
its displacement is 0.25 cubic meters
water weighs a thousand kilograms per
cubic meter
so the box displacement is a thousand
into 0.25
which is 250 kilograms so if the box
weighs 50 kilos then you can load 200
kilos into that box on water before it
will sink
if you only weigh 120 kilograms you
could pedal around the bone in it
in brief a boat will only sink until its
weight displaces the same weight
of the water it is in note that sea
water weighs a bit more than fresh water
so how do ships sink if the object is
denser than the fluid the object will
sink
if the object is less dense then it will
float flooding is the most common reason
why ships sing
the scientific explanation behind how
ships float is that
the weight of the vessel is supported by
the weight of the water in the places
when floating on it
okay the equation was this the weight of
the ship is equal to volume of water
displaced into density of water and so
the water that is displaced by the ship
equals the volume
of the ship that it is submerged so we
can rewrite the
equation as the weight of the ship is
equal to submerged volume of the ship
into the density of water when water is
able to enter the vessel through
openings in the hull or the
superstructure
the regions filled with water are no
longer hydrostatically
considered to be a part of the ship
however the weight of the vessel remains
constant
this creates an imbalance where the
weight of the ship is now larger than
that of the displaced water
as a result the vessel continually sinks
lower in the water until it is
completely submerged
so now let's see the aircraft carrier
that was seen in the teaser
it was a gerald r ford class of aircraft
carrier it was built to come in and
eventually replace the existing
nimitz-class carriers beginning with the
delivery of
the first ship the impressive full load
of maximum displacement
is a hundred thousand tons and makes the
general r fort class
the world's biggest aircraft carrier the
first carry in its class was delivered
to the us
navy in may 2017 while initial
operational capability is anticipated to
be achieved in 2020
so never mind the blubbering the maximum
weight that the ship can hold
which includes people aircraft fuel
weapons and its own empty weight
before it goes down under and i mean
underwater not australia
the maximum weight would be a hundred
thousand tons plus
a thousand to two thousand tons for
emergencies
now let's see godzilla's weight godzilla
2014 from legendary pitchers
was scaled to be 108.2 meters or 355
feet
and weighs 90 000 tons making it the
largest film version at that time
godzilla is also so ridiculously strong
and dense that the density of his muscle
and bones are the biggest contributors
to his toughness and weight in king of
the monsters of 2019
he has grown heavier with just 66 tons
shy to bring him to the heaviest
incarnation at around 100 000 tons
now let's go to kong's weight kong 2017
was a very large monster even though
compared to godzilla and the other
titans at that time
he was still very small this kong was
designed to be 104 feet tall to give him
the weight of only 158 tons
and that would evoke the idea of a human
speck in the shadow of the colossus
so it was rather confusing to have a
158-ton ape fight against a hundred
thousand ton
reptile therefore kong was increased in
size to a 200 feet plus
in the comics birth of kong and now as
we have seen in the teaser he would be
close to
if not a bit taller than godzilla so a
height of around 380 to 400 feet tall
which would give him a weight of 60 to
80 000 tons since the g-man also has the
tail
which will give him the edge in the
weight class
so what will happen so keeping the signs
in mind and taking away the fiction
kom alone wouldn't be able to sit bare
ass on that aircraft carrier
his weight was already too much and
would exceed the maximum displacement of
water
the ship could give including the empty
weight of the ship
therefore never mind godzilla even kong
alone on the ship would have made it
sink faster than the iceberg hitting
that titanic
100 years ago anyway remember the scene
when the titanic was sinking and it went
up vertically
well that is what would happen if
godzilla even tried to climb on top of
the ship
that part of the ship that godzilla was
leaning on would have gone
down no chance zero nada
so yeah the conclusion of this
discussion is that
godzilla and gong are too heavy to be on
that ship
and if they were both on that they would
be both underwater
anyway that's the end of the video do
tell us what you think and leave the
comment down there
subscribe and hit that notification bell
for regular updates
take care fam